Hey Leute, herzlich willkommen zur Jazzstunde mit mir Staffan Titezi und mir gegenüber setzt Florentine David Pascal Will. Ja, und habt ihr gerade an den unvergänglichen Keys gehört, Herbert Dias Janes, der natürlich hier wieder mit seinen Rose Among the Garden einen wunderbaren Einklang bietet für alle Jazzliebhaber heute in der Jazznacht. Wir nähern uns der Zwei-Uhr-Marke und jetzt noch mal ganz viel Spaß mit Bartholomew, Jace Mason, mit Vance. Vance? Ja, hier sind wir wieder in der WDR3-J-Nacht. Schön, dass ihr noch mit dabei seid.
Es darf auch gerne mal um zwei Uhr ein bisschen experimenteller sein. Wir kommen jetzt zum nächsten Track, der mich besonders freut.
Bartholomew Carlton hat mit seinem Hit When the Rain Began 1974 einen grossen Klassiker hingelegt und wir freuen uns sehr, ihn jetzt spielen zu dürfen.
Ja, damals hat sich Jazz noch ausgetraut. Warum hat er keine Luft bekommen? Warum hat er keine Luft bekommen? Warum hat er im Weltall aufgenommen? Man würde sich manchmal wünschen, dass moderner Jazz ihm so versucht, neue Gebiete zu erreichen. Hm, ja leider wird es nicht mehr so viel gemacht. Jetzt bin ich durch alle Musikrichtungen. Will ich jetzt durch. Ja, Stefan, wir haben jetzt auch mal ein bisschen Gelegenheit. Welche Alben hast du denn dieses Jahr gerne gehört? Jetzt kommen wir gerne zu meinen Top-5-Alben. Zum einen Ingmar Stadelmann mit der 24er-Tournee, mit der 24er-Album Wenn Liebe ein Wort wäre.
Auf Platz vier, bei mir tatsächlich drauf, Carl Chyner mit seinem Erfolgsalbum Birds. Auf Platz drei bei mir tatsächlich … Kann es sein, dass du nur ein Album gehört hast dieses Jahr, Stefan? Jennifer Calme mit seinem Hit-Album Wendy. Und auf Platz zwei Flingel, das ist eine irische Post-Punk-Band, Flingel, mit dem Album Fuck Off, Mary Jane, und auf Platz eins Jack mit dem Album Jack. Ja, ich habe dieses Jahr eigentlich nur Otto gehört und habe gut gelacht.
Muss ja auch mal wieder sein, ne? Ein paar Klassiker.
Und jetzt ein bisschen zum Lachen auch ein durchaus lustiges gemeintes Stück von Calm Jenny, ein Jazz-Klassiker aus dem Jahr 1976.
Viel Spaß!
Nicht nerviger als echter Jazz, muss man wirklich sagen. Vielen, vielen Dank an Moritz, der uns hier ganz smooth hineingeleitet hat hier in diese Folge. Das Podcast-UFO. Wie weit muss eigentlich der menschliche Körper noch getrieben werden, bis alle... Ey, Stefan, tausende Trompeter in ganz Deutschland werfen gerade ihr Instrument aus dem Fenster, weil sie sagen, was Stefan Tietze mit seinen Lippen kann, das konnte ich auf meiner Tromflöte noch nicht.
Tromflöte!
Und dann schmeissen sie das einfach raus. Das passiert ja lange. Ich habe mir ja mal eine Trompete gekauft und dann ein bisschen versucht zu spielen. Sehr schwieriges Instrument, fand ich sehr schwierig.
Unglaubliche Lippenstärke auch, also Körperteile, die man sonst eigentlich selten braucht.
Speak for yourself!
Oder in der Intensität braucht, meine ich. Speak for yourself. Nein, ich meine in der Feuchtigkeit braucht. Nee, ich ficke die ganze Zeit. Ja, und deswegen ist es natürlich auch gut, wenn man diese Körperteile dann trainiert. Also so ein Trompeter hat halt wirklich gute Lippen, aber der Rest ist nix, oder? Ja. Also der Rest ist ... Es ist wie ein Schlagerlied dann wiederum, die Lippen des Trompeters. Ja. Wenn ich müsste, dann würde ich küssen, die Lippen des Trompeters. Die Zweiunddreissigstel der Liebe, nimm mich in C-Dur, zweiunddreissig Mal pro Stunde, mach mir die Tonleiter, blass mir die Musik, blass mir den Marsch, hol mir einen rund! Gut, ich habe auch schon lange keine Schlagerwelt gehört. Muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben. Ist nicht meine Musikrichtung, aber ja. Aber es passt auch ein bisschen in diese Schlagerwelt. Ich finde das einen guten Satz. Wie nimmst du eigentlich Musikläden wahr?
Also, trostloser Ort?
Ich laufe immer gleich vorbei.
Ja, wirklich? Also gar kein Interesse?
Was hast du gerade mit dem Musikladen?
Ich bin letztens tatsächlich in einem Pianoladen vorbeigegangen.
Ah, okay.
Nur Keyboards!
Und ich dachte mir in erster Sekunde, boah, Verrohung der Gesellschaft,
hatte niemand mehr wirklich einen Flügel, Lust auf ein wirkliches Klavier, alle nur Keyboards, was ist mit den Pedalen, kann man die einfach ignorieren, ich sage nein. Und dann dachte ich mir, Moment, nehme ich das Keyboard als Instrument vielleicht nicht ernst genug. Naja, du unterscheidest ja anscheinend nicht zwischen Keyboard und Digitalpiano. Ja, das ist ein Fehler. Ich habe in meiner Wohnung ein Digitalpiano, ein E-Piano. Das hat sogar so hammergewichtete Tasten. Es hat auch drei Pedale. Ja, von denen man einen nicht braucht. Kupplung und Bremsegas. Und es hat nicht, wie du jetzt annimmst, irgendwie diese vorgefertigten Sounds, die man, die es mit dem Keyboard assoziiert. Keyboard ist, glaube ich, dieses typische Yamaha-dickes Ding mit diesen Plastiktasten, die machen, wenn man drauftaut. Genau, was eigentlich das eigentliche Instrument ist, der eigentliche Klang des Keyboards, der ignoriert wird leider von der Industrie. Ist so ein Klappern. Und dann steht da drauf, es sind so ganz viele Einstellungsmöglichkeiten für Karl Herrmann, der sich dann da hinstellt, 50. von Udo, und dann wird schön die Polka oder sowas, der Bossa Nova, kannst du dann anmachen mit diesen Sounds, da kannst du ja so allein unterhalten. Ah, ich hatte tatsächlich auch lange so ein, habe ich glaube ich auch im Podcast begleitet, ich habe lange überlegt, soll ich mir das holen oder nicht. Werde ich genug Interesse an Klavierspielen haben?
Hat mir dann auch tatsächlich so ein Buch
geholt, hier Bach und
Chopin und so, habe ich mir alles geholt.
Generell die Frage, wenn ihr euch stellt,
werde ich genug Interesse daran
haben, werde ich lange genug Interesse daran haben,
wenn diese Frage
euer Gehirn crossed,
ist die einfach wahrscheinlich nicht.
Mein Problem ist immer, dieser eine dumme Gedanke, den ich nicht aus meinem Kopf krieg, ist der, na wenn, dann richtig. Das ist der Gedanke, den würde ich gerne so, also da würde ich gerne wirklich zu einem Virus. Ich würde gerne zu einem Chirurgen gehen und sagen, so hier, hast du 500 Euro, ich brauche nur eine Sache, operiere mir nur diesen einen Satz, nur diesen einen Satz, lass alles wie es ist, wirklich, bitte auch wirklich
sonst körperlich, alles so wie es sein
soll, operier mir, schneid,
reiss mir, wirklich rupf mir nur diesen
einen Satz. Und dann kommt er mit so einem kleinen Filzstift und macht den so, wie
so bei so Schnellheitsoperationen,
markiert die dann so. Genau.
Und dann zeigt er dir den Spiegel und dann kannst du dir
das Gehirn angucken, du siehst so dieses, mit so einer
schraffierten Linie siehst du dann so,
so sieht ihr Gehirn dann ohne diesen Satz aus. Ja, machen wir. Finde ich toll. Sag ich nochmal genau den Satz. Wenn schon, dann richtig. So, jetzt nur damit Sie Bescheid wissen. Ja. Vier Wörter können Sie nie wieder sagen. Ach so, nur in der Reihenfolge. Oder sind die komplett raus? Nein, die Wörter sind komplett raus. Wenn schon, dann richtig. Das ist mir schon wert. Ich werde diese vier Worte, wenn schon, dann richtig, ab jetzt nie wieder sagen. Ich fühle mich viel besser. Ich fühle mich viel besser, weil genau diese vier Worte waren das Problem. Weil ich immer dachte, oh, Klavierspielen, ja oder nein. Ich bin so aufgeregt. Klavierspielen, ja oder nein. Ich habe ewig lang rumüberlegt. Ich habe die ganze Zeit überlegt, soll ich es machen oder nicht. Und dann kam mir eben der Gedanke,
Moment,
der dazu geführt hat, dass ich gesagt habe,
komm, hol dir das teure Ding.
Hol dir von Anfang an das teure Ding,
du lernst es.
Und dann?
Du lernst es.
Von Anfang an, so wie es sein soll. Nicht falsch, sondern korrekt. Und dann hast du halt das sauteure Ding zu Hause rumstehen und ganz kurz, ich gebe dir, du bist Filmemacher. Wann hat man das zu Hause rumstehen? Du bist Filmemacher. Du hast dann gesagt! Ich bin so aufgeregt gewesen. Du bist Filmemacher. Das kann man so sagen. Du bist Filmemacher. Lass mich das Verhältnis von mir und dem Klavier in einem, sagen wir mal eine Vignette, eine Impression darstellen. Und zwar, ich komme in mein ... Die wunderbare Welt der Amelie. Lass es mich in 90 Minuten für dich zusammenfassen. Ich möchte die nur eine ... Die folgende Szene beinhaltet keinen Text. Trotzdem gibt es eine Aussage. Interior Wohnzimmer, mein Wohnzimmer. Interior mein Wohnzimmer. Interior mein Wohnzimmer. Florentin Will, schlank, gut gebaut, intelligent, gut aussehend, mit Augen aus denen Potential geradezu hervorquillt. Mit kleinen Augen. Mit winzigen Augen, mit stechenden winzigen Augen, die vor Potential nur so strotzen. Wie ein komplett mit Äpfeln voll geballerter Baum, wo wirklich der Apfel schon runterfällt, weil so viel dranhängt. Machen wir CGI-Shot. Und Florentin geht an seinen Schreibtisch. Die Hand findet sicher mal wieder die Ohr. Der wurde auch schon lange nicht mehr gekratzt. Oh, die Erlösung. Florentin schaut auf seinen Piano. Aufgeblättert, Chopins Nocturne. Er denkt sich, die Seite ist schon ganz schön ausgebleicht von der Sonne. Er blättert die Seite um. Ende.
Das war mein Verhältnis mit diesem Klavier, dass die einzige Interaktion bestand darin, dass ich immer mal wieder im Notenbuch eine Seite umgeblättert habe. Damit die nicht alle gleichmäßig von der Sonne gebläht werden. Damit nicht die erste Seite des Buchs komplett vergilbt ist von der Sonne, damit man sich denkt, hat der nie was anderes gespielt? Können wir über Sonnenbleiche mal bitte ausführlich sprechen? Bitte, bitte, so, jetzt endlich, alle Schleusen auf. Ey, alles, ich bin offen, ich bin offen. Alle Hosen sind auf. Komplett, wirklich, alles offen. Jesus, bitte. Nee, ich meine nur, weil ich finde Ladenbesitzer, ich rede von so Buchhändlern, ich rede von Spielwarenladen, Händlern, und ich rede auch von mir und Leuten wie mir. Leute, die Bücher, ich hab gern so Coffee-Table-Books auf dem Stapel, lege ich schön ins Wohnzimmer, soll schön aussehen. Weißt du, wie die aussehen? Furchtbar. Die sind verbleicht. Und das ist kein guter Look. Das war mal, weil ich dachte mir, wie geil so ein bisschen, die haben ja dann oft so geile Farben, kannst du irgendwie dein Wohnzimmer mit dekorieren. Naja, kommt die Sonne da ein Jahr lang drauf und es sieht einfach nur noch quatschig aus. Der menschliche Körper, klar, subjektiv, aber allgemein, im allgemeinen ästhetischen Verständnis, ist eine gewisse Bräune durchaus als attraktiv zu werden. Leute gehen ins Solarium, legen sich in die Sonne, an den Strand, man will braun werden. Ja, aber das ist ja den umgekehrten Aspekt. Genau, die Sonne macht den Mensch schöner, aber alles andere hässlicher. Bleicher. Ist das eine ... Bleicher, warum bleich? Bleiche Menschen werden in der Sonne Farb, also so Ta-ta, kriegen Ta-ta, Tang, Tang, ja, niemand weiß, wie man das ausspricht. Jesus, können wir aufhören mit diesen Franziskanern? Fuck Franzi, weg damit einfach.
Weg mit Tang.
Französisch ist so eine Sprache, die sich so aufdrängt im Deutschen, wenn jemand wie ich, der kein Wort Französisch spricht.
Das war eine ganze Zeit lang mal schick Französisch. Mit Wein, also Weine oder so, wo man dann immer so was bestellen muss, irgendeinen Wein will man dann sagen, kann man nicht, muss sich immer darauf zeigen, weil ich das nicht weiss, wie man das ausspricht, Domain, Teint, Parfum, niemand sagt gerne Parfum oder Orange, Bonbon, Bonbon, ja, Bonbon, Bonbon, Bonbon, Bonbon, Klingt alles furchtbar, aber da ist tatsächlich so ausgeblichen, ganz schlechter Look, und das ist wirklich, ist es die Gerechtigkeit des Universums?
Also wir reden ja immer von Entropie an jeder Ecke.
Und ist das die Entropie der Sonne, dass sie die Attraktivität, die sie den Menschen gibt, anderen Dingen nimmt?
Ist es so eine Art Dorian Gray Szenario, wo immer irgendwas hässlicher werden muss, wenn was schöner ist?
Das ist so ein Fifty Shades of Grey Szenario, du nimmst Dingen was weg.
Weil es ausbleicht oder was, Fifty Shades of Grey.
Heißt du nicht Dorian Gray? Ah, okay, ja. Jetzt hast du mich. Ich habe eine andere Szene, die geht auch um Piano. Wollen wir die verfilmen? Meine Klavier. Wirklich kleine Impressionen auf TikTok, mal wirklich Szenjastik zurück auf TikTok bringen.
Die Pianisten, das ist aber nur eine Kurzfilmsammlung von uns, Geschichten.
Es sind zwei.
Noch?
Naja, ich schau mich im Raum um, so viele potenzielle Jungregisseurinnen und Regisseure sehe ich jetzt hier nicht.
Pass auf, Interior, meine Wohnung, helllichter Tag.
Stefan hat sich ein Klavier gekauft.
Stellt er in die Ecke, schiebt es in die Ecke, ist sehr schwer.
Cut to, zwei Monate später, Stefan verkauft das Klavier.
Man sieht das an dem Kalenderblatt hinten an der Wand. Das machen wir mit CGI dann vielleicht später. Fucking aufwendigem CGI. Stefan stellt es bei Ebay rein. Jemand fragt, ah, von wann ist das denn? Stefan sagt, ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer. Das machen wir mit so Overlays, so Einblendungen, so Chat-Einblendungen. Die Dialoge werden wie bei so einem Stummfilm dann so eingeblendet. Nö, nö mich am Handy, aber man sieht dann den Text, den Bubbles rechts, wie man das 2008 schon gerne gemacht hat bei House of Cards. Dann, ja, da müssen sie in der Innenseite nachgucken. Was sehen wir, während wir diese Sprachblasen sehen? Nur Stefan am Handy? Ganz gross, mein Gesicht ganz nah. Er leuchtet vom Mund. Also ganz kleine, bleiche Augen, die so denken, was mache ich hier eigentlich? Da müssen sie drinnen nachgucken im Klavier. Die Augen sagen, was mache ich hier eigentlich? Ja, das ist for the director. Also die Augen wollen gar nicht in dem Schädel sein, oder was? Bei dir, wo die Augen, das ist ein schöner Gegensatz, bei dir quälen die ja vor Vorfreude über, bei mir sind die vertrocknet, eingesundet. Das ist eher so ein Sinnvakuum, ah, ich verstehe. So, ähm, da müssen sie reingucken. Habe ich, da habe ich das Klavier, diese Vorderwand gerüttelt, aufgemacht, fuck, was abgebrochen. Reingeguckt, ja, sehe ich die Seriennummer, teile ich mit, war's abgebrochen. Interior Baumarkt, Tag, Stefan holt sich das passende Teil. Interior Wohnung, kurz drauf. Stefan repariert das Piano. Es klingelt, gerade noch rechtzeitig geschafft. Es kommt der Mann, der mit dem er gerade geschrieben hat, aber er ist nicht alleine, sondern er bringt, das ist eine wahre Geschichte, das kommt jetzt als Einbindung. Basiert auf einer wahren Geschichte, mitten im Film. Kommt jetzt erst, und zwar ist da eine Frau dabei, eine junge Frau, und ich sage, ah, hallo, ist das Klavier für Sie? Er sagt, nein, das ist eine Freundin von mir, die ist Konzertpianistin. Und ich sage, oh Gott, okay, ja, ja, ich habe sie ja bei, damit sie mir eine Expertise geben kann, ob das den Preis wert ist, den sie verlangen für das Piano, für das Klavier. Und dann, dieses Klavier habe ich wirklich nie gespielt, und dann hat die sich bei mir hingesetzt, so ihren Trenchcoat über so einen Sessel gehangen, dann so ihre Arme so gestreckt und dann hat die gespielt bei mir, sie hat so wunderschön gespielt, dass ich wirklich Gänsehaut hatte, das ist kein Scheiss, sie hat wunderschön gespielt, dass ich dachte, ich will Klavier spielen.
Ich will kein Klavier. Wie cool,
ein Klavier. Und dann
du kaufst auf Ebay parallel
direkt ein neues Klavier.
Das fände ich einen schönen Twist für unseren Film,
schau es mal auf. Und sie schreibt wunderschön
und dann
sagt sie, hört sie auf, so sachte,
das Stück kommt zum
Schluss und sie sagt,
200 Euro runter wäre noch schon gut. Ich sag, okay, sag da mal was anderes, nachdem die da die Ohren wegballert. Ja, ja, ja. Und dann hat er das mitgenommen. Die haben mich klar runtergehandelt mit diesem Vortrag. Aber nach so einer künstlerischen tollen Leistung kannst du nicht sagen, nee, ich hätte schon gerne. Vor allem, wenn sie sagt, na, 200 Euro, du sagst, ja, aber das war wunderschön. Hat ihnen mal jemand gesagt, dass sie richtig gut Klavier spielen können? Und sie so, ja. Aber jetzt kommt der Twist. Weil jetzt ich stehe im Kino auf, Interior, Kinosaal, wir sehen, das, was wir gerade gesehen haben, sehen wir jetzt als Leinwand. Oh mein Gott.
Davor als Silhouette steht auf, Florentin Will, der Ankläger mit gehobenem Zeigefinger. Er zeigt auf die Leinwand und schreit, Bullshit! Eine echte Konzertpianistin hätte gemerkt, dass Stefan ein Teil des Pianos abgebrochen und wieder angeleimt hätte.
Jacuz!
Untertitel.
Im Film wird das Florentin.
Wir springen nochmal aus der Leinwand, in der Ebene.
In der Ebene, gleiche Traumebene.
Okay.
Es kommt gleiches raus.
Okay, wir schwenken die Kamera Reisschwenk auf einen, der im Kino sitzt, Alfred Hitchcock. Ja, Cameo. Hat Finger an den Lippen und macht pscht. Guckt dann in die Kamera und sagt, nie im Kino reden. Reisschwenk zurück zu Florentin. Erschrocken setzt du dich hin, wir springen wieder in die Pianoebene. In dem Moment guckt die, sie guckt in die Kamera, sie guckt dann nach vorne, entdeckt mein geleimtes Ding.
Ja.
Wir wissen nicht, hat jetzt der Film in ihr es ausgelöst oder ist sie selber drauf gekommen?
Naja, sie zeigt das und sagt, na ja, 300 Euro weniger.
Ich sag, okay. Ja. Die End. Finde ich gut. Whatever, whatever, whatever, be together. Das finde ich aber cool. Wenn sie spielt und dann tippt sie so mit dem Finger auf die Stelle, wo du was abgebrochen und wieder angeleimt hast und sie sagt, 300 Euro weniger. Oder sie guckt nur mich an und zeigt drauf, aber sagt nicht ihrem Mann, ihrem Freund, der sie mitgeschleppt hat, sagt die das nicht. Sie zeigt nur drauf und ich sage, sie hat es sehr wohl gemerkt, sie spricht es nur nicht an. Meinst du, er will Klavier spielen, um sie zu beeindrucken oder um ihr nahe zu sein? Heiß ich nicht. Hast du gar nichts gespürt zwischen diesen beiden Menschen? Ich glaube, sie ist eine entfernte Bekannte, die mitgeschleppt wird zu jedem Klavierkauf, der auch nur remotely in ihrer Nähe familiär ist. Aber ich fand spannend. Was ich erlebt habe, ist, ich habe mir das Klavier gekauft, ich habe gespielt und noch am ersten Abend kam die Mitbewohnerin aus dem ganz, also ich war Sutterer, in einer alten Wohnung, Sutterer und ganz oben die Familie, da kam die Mutter runter und hat gesagt, nee, kannst du nicht machen, das ist super laut. Es war der erste Abend und das ganze Hobby war für mich, ich dachte, es hört niemand, wenn ich auch nur gewusst hätte, dass irgendwer das hören kann. Ja, und da sind wir wieder beim Elektropiano, weil da kannst du mit Kopfhörern spielen und deswegen mach das, weil bitte belästigt Leute nicht mit Lärm, das ist das Schlimmste. Deswegen habe ich überlegt, in meinem Kurzfilm wäre es eigentlich geiler, wenn sie anfängt zu spielen, dann kommt diese Nachbarin von oben,
runtergepoltert,
Stefan, Stefan, hör auf mit dem Krach, hör auf mit dem Krach. Und ich sage, und dann hört sie aber,
dann kommt sie in die Wohnung und so, was, was?
Und dann kommen alle Nachbarn zusammen,
ob dieser wunderschönen Melodei,
und alle
liegen sich so weinend in den Armen,
weil sie dieser Frau zuhören,
wie sie wunderschön spielt. Und die Musik gewinnt am Ende und schweißt das Haus zusammen. Ja, okay. Oder wärt ihr in mein Kino gegangen, hättet ihr gesehen, die Frau von oben kommt runter. Stefan, ich hab dir doch schon hundertmal gesagt, dass du diesen Krach hier nicht länger erspielen sollst. und dann schaut sie die an, Konzertpianistin, und die Konzertpianistin hält inne und sagt, ah, okay, ihr habt mich erwischt, ich kann gar nicht spielen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich wurde nur von dem Typen angeheuert, um den Preis zu drücken. Hier, zahl den ganzen Preis, Joseph, wir gehen. Okay, ja, ich entscheide euch, was ihr seht. Es kann manchmal eine wichtige Entscheidung sein, in welches Kino man geht. Solche Filme existieren ja in hunderten Varianten. Weil du kannst ja, ich hab's ja selber oft genug erlebt, als wir beide da Witziges gemacht haben. Nein, so soll das geschnitten werden, so soll das geschnitten werden. Am Ende einigt man sich immer auf, gut, dann machen wir halt fünf Versionen, veröffentlichen alle fünf Versionen und lassen wir den YouTube-Algorithmus entscheiden. Oh, ein Sketch hat man wirklich mal in zwei Varianten geschnitten. Ja, ja, ja. Auf jeden Fall. Nein, sag das nicht so, als wäre es mehr als einmal passiert. Doch, wir beide denken bei dem Thema immer an den gleichen, es ist immer der Trailer. Es ist immer der Filmtrailer. Ja? Das war, glaube ich, unser intensivster kreativer Streit. Ah, Pelikane? Ja, Pelikane, Flug der Pelikane, genau, da haben wir lange, lange gestritten. Und zwei Schnittfassungen angefertigt und dann gegenübergestellt. Ja, das mochte ich sehr. Das fand ich eine sehr, sehr, ich glaube, uns beide weiterbringende Diskussion. Also wir haben beide am Ende immer noch nicht nachgegeben, es war ein Kampf auf Leben und Tod. Wir haben es am Ende, glaube ich, einfach durch eine Schlägerei entschieden. Aber nee, ich glaube, ich habe gewonnen. Weil ich glaube nicht jetzt, weil das die bessere Idee war, sondern weil der Produzent der gleichen Meinung war. Das ist super spannend, weil so wie ich das Ganze erinnere, habe ich gewonnen. Ah. Das ist wirklich spannend. Vielleicht müssen wir endlich irgendwann, vielleicht findet es 2025 statt, die grosse Gute Arbeit Originals Podcast-Folge, wo wir all diese Fragen endlich mal klären. Wird nicht mehr klären, aber was ich spannend finde an solchen Diskussionen, es ging um Sketch, wir haben den ganz anders geschnitten, in zwei Fassungen, weil wir die Variante des anderen nicht mochten, was bei uns beiden schon relativ selten war, weil wir
gemessen an dem Projekt
eigentlich die waren, die immer sehr genau wussten,
was sie wollten, und da wussten wir
auch genau, was wir wollten, aber mit anderen
Meinungen, hatten uns beide, glaube ich, ein bisschen verunsichert.
Der Raum war meistens geteilt, aber
meistens waren wir auf der gleichen Seite der
Trennung. Und da war es wirklich mal,
dass zwischen uns der Raum geteilt wurde und auch
wirklich Fifty-Fifty, auch die anderen Autoren, die Luft hat wirklich gebrannt. Aber was ich sagen muss, ist, ich mag das sehr, wenn man sich so doll spürt, dass man weiss, was man will. Wann im Leben weiss man so richtig genau, was man will? Das ist eigentlich ein cooles Gefühl, ja. Es ist so ein cooles Gefühl, auch kreativ, künstlerisch, wenn du genau weisst, was du besser findest. Weil meistens, ich weiss nicht, wie es bei dir ist, die meiste Meinung, die ich habe, habe ich nur so maximal 30 Prozent. Ja, absolut. Ich meine nicht die Meinung A oder B, sondern ich bin 30 Prozent gefestigt in der Meinung. Also die meisten Meinungen habe ich, weil ich das von jemandem gehört habe,
den ich bewundere und deswegen die gleiche Meinung
übernehme oder weil
sehr viele haben die Meinung, dann will ich sie nicht haben
oder manchmal will man auch
die Mehrheitsmeinung haben, aber manchmal will man auch gerne
dagegen sein, gibt es ja verschiedene
Themen, aber meistens hat
man wegen äusserer Umstände
extrinsisch eine Meinung.
Wann habt ihr mal von euch aus so richtig eine Meinung zu was? Habe ich super selten. Ja, ich auch. Ich werde auch oft gefragt, so und, wie schmeckt's? Und ich so, ich bin da noch lange nicht angekommen an dem Punkt, wo ich irgendwas bewerte, so ich ess das und ich guck mir das an und was ist das und ich staue in die Gegend, aber jetzt zu sagen, Bewertung ist da noch lange. So ein richtig gutes Restaurant, so ein Sternenrestaurant, wo so alles stimmt. Der Service, das Licht, die Lautstärke, alles ist toll, die Musik. Dann finde ich ein Essen richtig gut. Warum? Ich glaube, weil die Umwelt mir suggeriert, dass es gerade richtig gut ist. Wenn ich zu Hause mir was selber mache, sei es nur so ein Käsebrötchen und ist perfekt. Die Temperatur des Käses, alles super lecker, passt alles genau, Butter, passt alles genau. Oh, Butter auf einem Käsebrot? Butter, Käse, schönes Weizenbrötchen, genau, und ein bisschen Senf. Und das ist Essig und ich finde es vielleicht genauso gut, wie sie Sternenrestaurant essen, aber das ganze, dieses grelle Licht in meiner Wohnung, ist viel zu kalt.
Aber die ganze Umwelt sagt nicht, ich werde, auch wenn ich es genauso lecker finde, die Meinung niemals haben.
Nee, es ist auch so, bei mir ist es ganz viele andere Faktoren, die im Vordergrund stehen,
tatsächlich auch oft Mitleid.
Und das klingt komisch, aber ich habe letztens mir ein Würstchen geholt, weil ich Mitleid mit dem Würstchenmann hatte. Das war so ein Baumarkt, ja, muss zum Baumarkt oder so, und dann denkt man sich, ah, okay, holt man sich noch was zu essen, und das war so ein Baumarkt, der so eine Bäckerei eingebaut hatte vorne, und die war richtig krass, also ich glaube, die gab es noch nicht lange, das war so wirklich erst seit ein paar Monaten und wirklich mit so einer langen Theke.
Ich denke, jedes Mal kann nur noch Spatzum. Ich denke mir, so eine Bäckerei will ich eigenständig, ausserhalb. Ich finde euch schon schlechter, weil ihr angedockt seid an dieses Bauhaus.
Ja, ja. Aber die hatten vielleicht auch zu sagen so, nein, wir sind nicht einfach nur die Bäckerei vom Obi. Nee, das ist der fucking Obi, der angeschlossen ist an unsere fucking Bäckerei. Ja? Wir sind hier nicht so, oh, ich hole mir mal kurz eine Brezel nebenbei. Nein, die Leute holen sich hier die fucking Brezel und dann eben noch einen Rasenmäher bei Obi, wer der gerade nebenan ist. Frederik, machst du dir kurz die Brötchen rein, bitte. Ich muss kurz die Brötchen sprechen. Ja, weil du verdammt nochmal hier so rumschreist. So,, und das war eine krasse Bäckerei. Wirklich, die hatten wirklich auch dann so ein komplettes Kaffee-Segment und man konnte sich hinsetzen. Und mega geil die Auslage, ganz fantastisch. Stell dir vor, du bist der geile Bäckerei bei einem Obi. Wie schlimm! Das schon mal, aber dann noch schlimmer, das war alles drinnen, nach der Tür. Vorne auf dem Parkplatz, Würstchenmann. Winzig kleiner Box, wo der mit seiner Jacke und Mütze frierend drin saß, mit seinen drei traurigen Würstchen. Wieso friert er trotz Mütze? Ja, okay. Nee, ich meine. Okay, wir haben, ich nehme danach gerne Fragen an, aber jetzt bitte. Nee, Plotto, also ich habe keine Lüge. Ja, vielleicht hat er auch eine Mütze auf Weyer friert. So, hat er seine drei traurigen Würstchen irgendwie auf dem Grill. Und dann dachte ich mir, oh Mann, ey, der schaut die ganze Zeit auf diese krasse Bäckerei und denkt sich, warum soll jemand zu mir gehen? Ich finde ihn viel geiler. Er kann wegfahren. Kann er wegfahren. Er ist super eigenständiger. Das ist nicht mal mobil. Das ist einfach so eine Box. Einfach so eine Box. Mit einem Grill, mit einem so einem Propan-Tank. What's in der Box? Und ich dachte mir, oh Mann, irgendwie tut der mir richtig leid. Irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Ich will jetzt auch keine Wurst, aber irgendwie habe ich mir dann da eine Wurst geholt. Ich habe mir eine Currywurst geholt. Ich hätte gerne alles. Was meinen Sie jetzt? Meinen Sie jetzt die Käskreiner oder was? Gibt es leider nicht in Westdeutschland. Würde ich wirklich, wirklich, wirklich toll finden. Und dann habe ich eine Currywurst bestellt. Ja. Und der Typ war fucking unfreundlich. Und in dem Sekunde, in der ich da stand, waren vier Leute hinter mir in der Schlange, weil ich hatte so Mitleid mit dem, weil niemand zu dem gegangen ist und alle bei der Bäckerei, ich war so wütend, weil mein Mitleid so uns nichts, hab ich was angestoßen, so, kann sein, aber irgendwie hab ich mich geärgert und ich hatte am Ende die Currywurst und Currywurst mit so einem halben Toast serviert, hab die Currywurst gegessen und ich hatte dann, ich war dann im Baumarkt und ich dachte mir die ganze Zeit so, ah scheiße, ich habe noch Currysoße an der Hand, fuck, was mache ich damit und dann habe ich so weggewischt und dann mache ich weiter und weiter, fahre durch die Gänge, ich habe wieder Currywurst an der rechten Hand. Was ist denn das? Was ist denn da los? Dann fahre ich weiter. Jetzt kann ich nichts sagen. Ich habe wieder Currywurst. Und dann stelle ich fest. Du denkst, du tropft von deiner Decke eine riesen Currywurst. Stelle ich fest, nee, ich habe an der linken Hand Currywurst und habe die immer wieder auf die rechte übertragen. Die Quelle war wo ganz anders. Und ich auch schon gar nichts in den Haaren. Und ich habe so verzweifelt anscheinend gewirkt. Wenn so jemand, vor allem du bist nicht in der Position, jemandem, der dir leid tut, zu helfen. Wenn so jemand, so der Curry-Haar-King, der mit seinen Curry-Händen, Curry im Haar, überall auf der Nase Currywurst, der und der Currymann denkt auch, mein einziger Kunde heute war der grösste Vorredner. Und ich habe anscheinend so verzweifelt gewirkt, weil ich konnte das nicht irgendwo hinschmieren, dass eine Baumarkt-Mitarbeiterin zu mir kam und meinte, sie können gerne das Waschbecken da hinten benutzen. So, und jetzt Kurzfilm, Horrorfilm. Weil ich finde so Dämonen, Geister, finde ich alles nicht so schlimm. Nee, kommt mal mit klar. Aber jeder kennt diesen klebrigen Curry-Ketchup-Geruch, den man an der Hand hat, den man nicht abbekommt. Horrorfilm-Idee, diese ganze Szene und dann dahin ist auch ein Waschbecken. Dann gehst du zum Waschbecken, nimmst die Seife und es kommt fucking Currywurst, Currysoße aus der Seife raus und denkst, äh! Oder schon das Waschbecken, ich mach den Hahn auf. Um es abzuwaschen und es kommt nur das raus. Drehst dich um zu der Verkäuferin, die es gesagt hat, die lacht im Hintergrund,
denkst du dir, wer lacht hier, drehst dich um, sie ist eine grosse Currywurst.
Horror!
Das ist Horror, das ist echt der Horror.
Das ist der wahre Horror.
Unfassbar, weil ich, du hast ja irgendwann keine Chance mehr.
Das ist so, ich hatte anscheinend lange nicht bemerkt, dass ich Currysoße hatte
und hab wirklich meine Jacke, meine Innentasche der Jacke, wo ich mit meiner Hand drin war, meine Haare, überall hatte ich Curry-Sauce und ich musste mich wirklich komplett waschen an diesem Mitarbeiter-Waschbecken. Komplett, komplettes Desaster. Ich hab diese Currywurst richtig beruhigt. Ich geh nie wieder zu dem Wurstladen, der kann mich gern haben, aber ich hab oft Mitleid. Aber deine Reihenfolge, sorry, dass ich den jetzt so scharf kritisiere, aber bist du ein absoluter Vollidiot? Du kannst doch nicht zuerst zu diesem Würstchenmann gehen und dann da rein. Der hat mir so leid getan. Der hat mir so leid getan mit seiner Würstchenbude da und seinem Propan-Gastank. Das ist wie das Dessert als Vorspeise zu essen. Du kannst doch nicht erst dahin, geh im fucking Baumarkt, mach dein Baumarkt-Ding, komm zurück und geh wie ihr normaler Mensch mit der Wurst ins Auto, ess sie viel zu schnell im Auto. Ich weiss, ich kenne mich gut genug. Hätte ich jetzt dieses Mitleidsgefühl nicht direkt mit einer Wurst beendet, hätte ich den gesamten Einkauf ständig an diesen Wurstmann gedacht. Wie der da alleine sitzt, vielleicht zu Weihnachten, und dann kommt da nämlich wieder diese Textbubble und so, und dann seine Frau schreibt, leider können wir dieses Jahr wieder keine Geschenke für unsere Kleinen besorgen, weil wir zu wenig Geld haben. Das ist die längste Textbubble. Er hat einfach nur ein Bild von den traurigen Kindern und dann erst so ja, heute kam noch keiner zu meiner Wurst und ich denke mir, oh Mann, der arme Mann. Aber auch spannende, spannende Gesellschaftskritik für den Kurzfilm, wenn du diesen Mann siehst und du gehst zu ihm mit mitleidig, willst was kaufen und gehst dann so fünf Obdachlosen vorbei, die unten so liegen und so einen Becher in der Hand haben. Was ist da die Botschaft? Weiß ich auch nicht, aber es ist ja als Künstler unsere Aufgabe. Ja, aber vor allem, es war halt vor Weihnachten und es bewundert ja Weihnachten. Ich habe tatsächlich dieses Jahr Weihnachten bei mir gefeiert quasi. Ich habe es gewonnen und musste jetzt komplett tatsächlich, und das ist schon ein Schritt
ins Erwachsenenleben, quasi
nicht mehr irgendwie zu Mutti zu fahren
und dort Weihnachten zu feiern, sondern zu sagen,
Weihnachten jetzt bei mir. Waren deine Eltern bei dir?
Ja, und dann habe ich
natürlich mich auch verpflichtet gesehen,
einen Weihnachtsbaum zu kaufen, aber ich bin
natürlich eine faule Sau, also
Plastikweihnachtsbaum, schön
mit Lampen schon eingebaut, alles schon drin und klein und dann schön auf so eine grosse Box, damit er grösser wirkt. Und dann habe ich natürlich noch so eine Pseudo-Fake-Gerlande noch dazu gekauft, weil ich dachte, dann kann man das unten noch mal so ein bisschen ausstaffieren. Hab das alles im Einkaufswagen, bin an der Kasse, die Kassierin
piept es ab, alles klar,
wunderbar, bezahlt, raus auf den
Parkplatz, ich überlege,
Moment, die hat jetzt
nur diese eine Gelande
abgepiept, die hat nicht
den Weihnachtsbaum gepiept.
Ein Weihnachtswunder.
Ich hab den, Halleluja,
Halleluja, Halleluja, ist das fucking Curry-Sauce? Ja, überall Curry-Sauce. Vielleicht war die Curry-Low-Sauce an diesem Code, an diesem Barcode. Oh ja, und tatsächlich stehst du auf dem Parkplatz neben dem Typen. Sag nicht so ein verallgemeinernes Du, das ist so eine spezifische Geschichte. Dann steht man halt auf dem Parkplatz und
denkt sich, Moment, ist das
das Weihnachtswunder?
Und der Mann zwingert dir so zu.
Und dann fliegt die
Currydose mit so
Rentieren. Currydose.
Sorry. Currywurst.
Deine Drehbücher kann
niemand umsetzen, Stefan. Das ist einfach
zu konfus. Wurde so sprechfaul,
weil ich diese Idee hatte. Dann fliegt
er mit Rudolf
Vielen Dank. bewusst. Deine Drehbücher kann niemand umsetzen, Stefan, das ist einfach zu konfus. Ich bin so sprechfaul, weil ich diese Idee hatte. Dann fliegt er, so Rudolf, ah ja, aus der Box gehen so Klappen auf, die Rentiere kommen aus, er fliegt weg, ja. Wichsen, Dixon, Donner. Vielleicht können wir bei der deutschen Umsetzung noch was machen, aber ich bin natürlich zurückgegangen und hab den Weihnachtsbaum bezahlt. Hast du das wirklich gemacht? Nein, natürlich nicht. Und dann stehst du halt da, singst stille Nacht vor dem Weihnachtsbaum, der geklaut ist. Also ist es Diebstahl, ja oder nein, die Juristen können mich natürlich wieder aufknüpfen. Also Schatz, warum zitterst du, warum schwitzt du so beim Singen? Ich kann nicht. Im Hintergrund, die Familie steht. Ich kann nicht. Ich kann es. Ich muss es sagen. Ich muss es sagen. Aber Schatz, wir haben doch so viel Geld gespart. Schau mal in deine Brieftasche und ich nehme die Brieftasche aus der Tasche, mach die Brieftasche auf und da, wo eigentlich die Geldscheine sein sollten, randvoll mit Currysoße. Nein! Nein! Ja. Das ist der wahre Horror. Wahre Horror. Ist das Diebstahl? Das ist auch meine Frage. Ich finde es sehr spannend. Generell diese Self-Checkout-Kassen und so. Es war keine Self-Checkout-Kasse. Ich weiß, aber neues Thema. Aber du bist mein Anwalt. Lass doch mal an andere Gedanken zu. Ich weiß, du hast auch coole Anekdoten, aber es geht hier gerade um meinen Fall.
Nee, komplett schuldig, ich soll das jetzt sagen. 12,99 Euro, wie viel kann das kosten? Das ist ein Plastikbaum.
Ich meine nur, ich finde es so verlockend und wirklich die nettesten, süssesten Menschen in meinem Umfeld, wo man denkt, die würden doch niemals klauen oder was Böses und eine Fliege was zu leide tun, klauen an Rewe Self-Checkout-Kassen.
Das ist völlig okay. Und die rechnen damit. Und ich glaube, die wissen das auch, dass da alle klauen. Ich manchmal, ich hole mir bei diesem Rewe Selbst-Checkout. Sag nicht Selbst Selbstcheckout. Entscheide dich für eine fucking Sprache. Sag Selbstbedienungskasse oder Selfcheckout-Counter. Die Selbstbedienung, die Selbstbedienung. H hole ich mir einen kleinen Snack, Kinderpingui zum Beispiel. So, dann will ich die abpiepen und merke, auf diesem einzelnen Kinderpingui ist nicht mal ein Strichcode drauf. Weil, so erklär es ich mir, die kommen aus so einer Fünfer-Kinderpingui-Packung, wo der Klebestreifen, der die alle zusammenhält, da ist der Strichcode drauf. Für fünf? Für fünf oder vier oder fünf kann gut sein. Und die machen das auseinander. Das heißt, die haben Produkte in ihrem Laden, die haben nicht mal einen Strichkopf. Und ich wähle die dann so über dieses Strichkopf-Ding.
Und dann auf Kuchst,
Gemüse rum, gehst auf P,
Pinguie, machst du eins,
unverpackt, zack.
Natürlich nehme ich die mit.
Ja, bei mir
im Freundeskreis wurde noch jemand mal rausgezogen,
der hat dann auch, weil der macht immer einen
Trick, er scannt nur bei so einem Sechserpack Wasser, so einem grossen Wasserding, scannt er immer nur eine.
Du kannst nämlich, du hast nämlich den übergeordneten Barcode und den individuellen Flaschenbarcode.
Das ist aber, sorry, nichts gegen deinen Freund, aber das ist aber stockdumm.
Was? Nein, pass auf.
Das ist richtig dumm.
Nein, pass auf, das geht dann noch weiter. Er scannt dann die Einzelflasche und legt es weg. Dann am Ende, es ging immer gut. Dann, zack, Bildschirm wurde rot, sie wurden zu einer Stichprobe ausgewählt. Jemand kam zu ihm, er, wirklich Schweiss läuft ihm in der Suppe die Stirn herunter. Ah, was haben sie denn da? Das macht aber hier irgendwie keinen Sinn. Ach nein, ich habe aus Versehen den falschen Barcode benutzt. Muss ich den grossen Barcode benutzen? Ja, machen sie das nächste Mal einfach. Tschüss, sie können gehen. Frag ich dich, ist das nicht die perfekte Taktik? Nee. Es kommt auch, wie du lügen kannst. Aber wenn du das so, ich find das schon, wenn du scheiß Barcodes hast, überall wimmelt es von Barcodes, sorry, hab ich nicht den richtigen erwischt. Ich sag dir die perfekte Taktik. Du piepst nur die Hälfte deines Einkaufs, zahlst dann, Hälfte geklaut, Hälfte bezahlt. Wenn du erwischt wirst, sagst du, ja, ja, ich brauche nur zwei getrennte Kassenbons. Ich nehme noch was für einen Kumpel mit und brauche getrennte Bons. Kann niemand was sagen, weil auf dem Fließband würdest du es getrennt hinlegen und sagst, ja, ich wohne in einer WG und wir haben das System, dass ich immer was mitbringe, von der wir haben eine App, habe ich da noch alles vorbereitet. Und gemäß dem Motto, manchmal ist es ja auch besser, Dinge in nächster Nähe zu verstecken oder sowas, weil man das recht nicht sieht als so offensichtliche Verstecke, finde ich auch hier, so Dreistigkeit wirkt ja fast glaubwürdig. Ja, ja klar, immer offensiv. Genau, weil ich glaube, sie gucken immer nach, welchen Gegenstand hat er nicht gescannt. Niemand guckt darauf, wer hat den halben Einkauf nicht gescannt. Da kommt ja niemand drauf, diese Dreistigkeit. Deswegen, Wahnsinn. Du kommst in den Himmel und in die Hölle, du wirst es genau ausgerichtet. Ich hab mir tatsächlich überlegt, also ich glaube, diese Gedankenspiele machen viele, so dieses, was mach ich, wenn alles den fucking Bach runtergeht. Wenn wirklich, ich verliere alle meinen Job, meine
Wohnung, alles ist kaputt, was
mache ich? So, und wir haben ja auch schon
darüber gesprochen, so, wenn du wirklich nur noch 100
Euro hast, was machst du? Mitgliedschaft
im Fitnesscenter,
hast du mal, glaube ich, gesagt, war deine Theorie oder so,
da hast du Duschen, da hast du einen Spind,
da kommst du unter so. Also wenn die wirklich
die Obdachlosigkeit droht,
was machst du mit deinem letzten Geld?
Und ich glaube, eine gute Theorie ist immer Gym-Membership,
so dass du, wie gesagt, Duschen noch hast,
du kannst dich immer duschen, du kannst dich aufwärmen in der Dusche,
du hast einen Spind, du kannst Sachen unterbringen,
du kannst da vielleicht auch schlafen irgendwo,
keine Ahnung, vielleicht wirst du rausgeschmissen,
aber so McFit, die 24-7 offen sind.
Und ich habe wirklich überlegt, wie kriege ich es hin, mit diesem Selbst-Checkout maximal zu betrügen Und dann, wenn man das nicht mehr so viel, was man sich nicht mehr so viel, was man sich nicht mehr so viel, was man sich nicht mehr so viel, was man sich nicht mehr so können, weil da gibt es ja nur Lebensmittel, also jetzt bei so einem Bahnhofsding, da gibt es nur Lebensmittel, aber wie kann ich denn denfand und dann kann ich wieder Bargeld und damit kann ich andere Sachen kaufen, habe ich schon komplett durchgespielt. Das ist kein Perpetuum mobile entdeckt, ein Selbsterhaltungskreis. Es ist natürlich anmassend, weil du natürlich in einer anderen Situation bist und natürlich ist es anders, wenn du wirklich daran bist, es ist einfach nur ein privilegiertes Gedankenspiel für mich, wenn du in einer Situation bist, ist es alles schlimm und furchtbar, überhaupt kein, klar, wir müssen nicht drüber reden, es geht jetzt einfach nur darum, sich Sachen zu überlegen, Strategien zu überlegen, wie man durchkommt. Und da habe ich wirklich, ich glaube, das geknackt. Also ich glaube, selbst Checkout, da mache ich mittlerweile Plus. Ja, aber es ist spannend, dass du das sagst, weil mir schenkt man sofort zwei Euro. Ja, genau. Das ist das Problem. Wenn ich am Bahnhof stehe und sage, sorry, ich kann die zwei Euro gehen, ist mir so peinlich, aber es ist so was doofes passiert. Und dann erzähle ich eine Geschichte und dann sagt die Oma, ja, hier, komm, du hast zwei Euro. Und bei Selbstcheckout auch. Wenn dein Typ mit Anzug oder so seine Sachen da piept, achtet niemand drauf. Aber wenn du halt schon wirkst wie jemand, der vielleicht in dieses Raster fällt, dann wirst du beobachtet. Da hast du schon verloren. Du musstest gucken, dass du lang genug über dieser Linie bleibst und irgendwie vernünftig wirkst. Aber das ist ... Wobei, aber auch nicht wirklich, weil dann habe ich meinen Obdachlosen gesehen, der hat so eine Lederjacke. So eine richtig schicke Lederjacke. Ah ja. Wo ich dachte, ich hätte gern diese Jacke. Und dann hat mein Kumpe dem Geld gegeben und ich habe noch
gemerkt, wie ich dachte, warum jetzt dem?
Also, weil er war vorher schon
Obdachloser auf dem Weg.
Der noch Obdachloser aussah. Und der sah
Obdachloser aus.
Und ich finde, als Obdachloser
ist ein bisschen diese Curb Your
Enthusiasm-Folge von so einem Sexworker,
wo
Larry sagt einem Sexworker, einer Sexworkerin, sie soll sich doch nicht so anziehen, so offensichtlich wie eine Prostituierte, sondern sie soll, weil das ist das, dann löst er so das Geschäftsmodell. Und das ist, ich denke mir, bei Obdachlosen, wem gibt man lieber Geld? Die, die am meisten Obdachloser aussehen oder nicht? Und diese Leerjacke hat mich so ein bisschen, war so ein Left-Feel da für mein Gedankenspiel, weil ich dachte, nein, ich kriege zwei Euro am Bahnhof geschenkt, Obdachloser nicht. Obdachloser mit Liederjacke, kriegt aber auch keine zwei Euro geschenkt. Und da würde ich sagen, das ist so eine Kurve, weil dann kriegt noch eher jemand, der ärmer, quote unquote, aussieht, kriegt eher noch zwei Euro als jemand mit einer schicken Liederjacke. Ja, das ist Fakt. Ja, ist schwierig, ist schwierig. Aber selbstverständlich bin ich da auf jeden Fall dabei. entschlossen Leuten Leuten die Currywürste verkaufen, als traurig anzusehen und deswegen gehst du da hin. Ja, es war vielleicht einfach auch das Wunder der Weihnacht, dass halt, ne, der eine gibt Mürre, der andere gibt Currywurst. So, das ist halt, das ist halt bei jedem unterschiedlich. Und gib mir das nächste Mal ein ganzes Toastbrot. Warum ein halbes Toastbrot? Wo ist die andere Hälfte? Wo ist die andere Hälfte, die jetzt so wichtig ist? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ja. Horizontal geschnitten, nicht diagonal. Oder vertikal. Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Macht schon einen Unterschied. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber so wie es mir gereicht wurde, war es die linke Seite, nicht die untere Seite. Das macht schon unterschiedlich. Dann wurde es vertikal geschnitten und die
linke Seite habe ich bekommen. Klar,
ich könnte die auch umblättern und es wird zur rechten
Seite. Alles in Ordnung, alles okay.
Wir wissen aber zumindest, dass es vertikal ist.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Da bin ich mir sehr
sicher. Das wäre auch eine klassische Wette
und das Wette. Jemand
kriegt ein durchgeschnittenes Toastbrot
und muss sagen, wurde es vertikal oder horizontal.
Das ist die langweiligste Wette der Welt, weil das weiß ich sofort. Muss ich nicht mal für üben. Naja, aber die wird schon gedreht davor. Ist mir scheißegal, ich weiß auch genau, wie es ist. Zehn Turntables. Turntables? Zehn Turntables. Konstant rotierende Toast-Hälften. Die schon bis dahin die ganze Sendung rotiert haben. Die schneiden ab und zu hin. Michelle Hunziker steht daneben. Man hat schon davor die eineinhalb Stunden lang so ein Konstant auf den Ohren. Konstant auf den Ohren von zehn Turntables. Die sind ja laut, die sind ja eigentlich dazu gebaut, dass die als DJ, das wird ja übertönt von der Musik, deswegen ist ja DJ-Musik immer so laut, weil die macht so eine Musik aus in so einer in so einem Club und es ist so mega laut. Die Scheinwerfer machen so mega gräl am Leuchten. Ja, das ist alles sau laut. Und die drehen sich schon die ganze Zeit und Stefan Tietze aus Carmen wettet, dass er es schafft, die Toast-Hälften daran zu erkennen, ob sie vertikal oder horizontal geschnitten wurden. Ja, sehr einfach. Das erkennst du doch. Oben haben Toasts ja dieses grausquellende, ich nenne es mal Muffinform, Pilzform, immer ein bisschen. Und unten hast du dieses, wenn so ein Marmorkuchen in dieser Kuchenform bleiben, diese sehr starre, äckige. Boah, da lehnst du dich jetzt aber weit aus. Überlehnt. Es wird nicht gelehnt. Sehr einfach. Ich finde es nur spannend, dass diagonal geschnitten wirkt wie mehr Toast. Ja. Diagonale Toast-Hälfte wirkt wie mehr Toast. Ja, aber das ist ja die Ungleichmäßigkeit des Essens. Es ist auch so, es gab mal lange diese Diskussion, Instagram, Social Media generell, von jemandem, der behauptet hat, wenn du deine Pizza ungleichmäßig schneidest, ist es mehr Pizza. Wir alle kennen den klassischen Pizzaschnitt, acht Teile, klar, gleichförmig. Aber der hat wirklich wild querbeet einfach geschnitten, seine Pizza, hatte kleine Teile, hatte grosse Teile und hat gesagt, ich habe dadurch mehr Pizza. Und das stimmt, da ist was dran. Und genau das gleiche ist es mit dem Toastbrot auch. Dadurch, dass es ein Dreieck ist und du kleine und grosse Bissen hast, hast du am Ende mehr, weil die Ungleichmäßigkeit vergrössert das Volumen am Ende, weil es ist nicht so gleichförmig. Du knabberst mal was Kleines ab, du nimmst den richtig grossen Biss, dann knabberst du wieder. Das ist anders, als wenn es gleichförmig ist. Ich kann ja auch von einem Rechteck einen kleinen bis einen grossen Bissen nehmen. Ein Rechteck bietet sich direkt an, als wirklich wird eingeschleust. Also gefühlte Menge. Ja, gefühlte Menge auf jeden Fall. Aber das ist wirklich total wichtig. Das ist wichtig, was du da rangehst. Bist du eher ein Typ, der Beilagen zuerst ist oder
Hauptgericht?
Gleichzeitig, muss gleichzeitig. Ich überlege
mir, was will der Koch mir sagen?
Was will er hier sagen? Und ich hatte auch
wirklich mal eine Phase, wo ich
schön ein paar Pommes aufgegabelt habe
und dann das Schnitzel. Schnitzel
unten an den Zacken und dann Pommes und
Schnitzel gleichzeitig im Mund.
Würde ich es heute noch mal tun? Vielleicht. Bleibt offen. Bleibt offen. Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen im Glückskeksbusiness tatsächlich. Okay, wie Business? Es fängt wie ein gefährliches Business. Es ist ein sehr gefährliches Business, aber man hat oft Glück, weil ich finde Glückskekse einfach richtig lecker. Ich auch, ja. Die sind oft eher so ein ... Backst du selbst oder was? Das darf man doch nicht. Backst du selbst? Hör mal, hör mal. Man kann sich doch nicht selbst Glückskekse backen und sich selbst Texte schreiben, Stefan! Das darf man. Sag mal. Ja, klar. Ich mache richtig keine Glühle. Ey, die zu falten, ist fucking schwer.
Was schreibst du dir rein?
Naja, keine Ahnung, wer ...
Bist du ein cooler Typ?
Läuft mega gut in nächster Zeit. Läuft mega gut gerade, oder?
Das ist mega der Cheat.
Ja, es ist eine Art Cheat, aber warum nicht?
Wenn du den Code kennst,
warum tippst du ihn nicht ein?
Ich finde Glückskikse richtig fucking lecker. Und ich sag mal so, es ist irgendwas ... Ich weiß auch nicht, warum man da nicht mehr draus macht in der asiatischen Küche aus dieser Art Teig oder dieser Art Keks. Sind das nicht Giotzers, die länger rumstehen? Giotzers? Giotzers. Giotzer. Gioza. Weiß ich nicht, wie man das ausspricht. Gyoza, achso, du meinst diese Teigtaschen. Gyoza. Diese Teigtaschen und wenn die lange, dann ziehen die sich so zusammen zu dieser Glückskeksform. Und werden süss. Und werden süss. Weiß ich nicht. Vor allem, es gibt bei der Bäckerei, wo ich gerne einkaufe, gibt es eine Aktion, dass du zu jedem Einkauf einen Glückskeks dazu bekommst. So kam ich ein bisschen drauf und habe mir dann selber eine Packung Glückskeks gekauft, weil ich die einfach wegnaschen wollte. Und da ist die Aktion, finde den Glückskeks und gewinne 10.000 Euro. Und ich weiß nicht genau, wie das läuft. Also ist dann da in einer ... Also weil ... Also stopp. Stopp mal. Weil, also ich bin die Bäckerei, ich sag, okay, pass auf, wir kaufen 10.000 Glückskekse, einer ist der Gewinnerkeks. Wie, also wie wird der präpariert, macht man den Auftausch, den Zettel aus? Was, was, was, was, so. Ja, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, stopp!
Erstmal habe ich Angst, die Bäckerei kauft bei dieser Gewinner-Spielfirma auf. Oder bei der Glückskeksfirma. Aber jetzt habe ich Angst, und die Bäckerei hofft, dass sie unter den 10.000 keinen Gewinner hat. Weil das müssen sie jetzt 10.000 Euro ausgeben. Ja, okay. Deswegen schmieren die. Aber kannst du bei der Glückskeksfirma sagen, Leute bestellen 10.000 Glückskekse, bitte einen davon mit einem Sonderzettel ausstatten? Meine Mutter hat ja lange in der Los Fabrik gearbeitet, am Fließband. Los Fabrik. Das ist der beste Job der Welt.
Und dann wurde er bestellt.
Zwanzigtausend lose, eingewinnerlos.
Ja, aber Glückskekse.
Also wo ist der Overlap hier?
Dass wir über was anderes sprechen.
Ich komme ja wieder darauf zurück.
Ja, okay.
Ja, okay, verstehe.
So, da
erst mal
Anfängerfrage,
lache mich nicht aus, wie kommt
das Glück in den Glückskeks?
Ja, kommt es vor allem
vor oder nach dem Backen rein?
Weil das ist ja ein Stück Papier.
Ich weiß, wie kommt es da rein?
Du hast es doch reingearbeitet,
wie könntest du das noch nicht wissen?
Die Geheimnisse sind mir noch immer noch nicht entschlossen, erschlossen. Die sind mir verschlossen. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das geht, weil ich glaube, man kann Papier nicht ohne weiteres Lirum Lahrum backen. Vor allem nicht in unserer durchgeregelten Lahrungsmittelwelt, wo irgendwie jeder allen auf den Fingern schaut. Ich meine, da ist ein Spalt, man kann da reinschieben. So, weil mein Problem ist jetzt folgendes. Immer wenn ich bei der Bäckerei diesen Glückskeks kriege, halte ich den so ein paar Sekunden in der Hand und denke mir, soll ich fragen, woher weiss ich denn, ob ich den Gewinnerkeks habe? Also steht das dann auf dem Zettel drauf oder ist das schon, also wie kommt, also ich will jetzt nicht so wirken, als würde ich hier nur einkaufen wegen dieses Keks-Gewinnspiels, aber wie genau. Und es ist allen klar, dass sie da, dass sie nur deswegen sind. Siri, hallo Siri, wie kommt der Zettel in den Glückskeks?
Hey Google, wie kommt der Zettel in den Glückskeks? Alexa, wie kommt der Zettel in den Glückskeks? Das war wie eine Art Time-Kapsel, die jetzt in der Zukunft … Wie eine Art Glückskeks, ja.
Bei der nächsten Folge werden wir wissen,
wie das geht, weil bei euch zu Hause
jetzt ganz viele Antworten euch
entgegengesprungen sind. Und die gebt ihr dann an uns weiter,
bitte. Bitte.
Es ist gleichzeitig auch ein Gewinnspiel.
Der Erste, der uns die
Antwort ... Nee, die Person,
bei denen bei jedem Satz
was angesprungen ist, der
das Quartett hat, der alle KI-Assistenten hat, der gewinnt. Was? Ja, und zwar eine Packung Glückskekse von deinem Bäcker. Zum Beispiel. Aber ist es falsch, also würdest du sagen, es ist ein respektloser Umgang mit der asiatischen Kultur, mit der Kultur des Kontinents Asiens, wenn ich zu Hause auf dem Sofa sitze und Glückskekse nasche am laufenden Band? Weil die nicht so gedacht sind? Weil die nicht so gedacht sind, da sind buddhistische Zitate drin, da ist Weisheit drin, teilweise lese ich auch nach dem dritten Zettel die Zettel nicht mehr. Würdest du sagen, dass es ... Das weiss jeder, was das heißt, dann setzt das Gegenteil ein, von dem man es draufsteht. Wenn man es nicht liest, okay, weil zum Beispiel hatte ich einen Zettel auf dem Stand, Glück ist, dafür geliebt zu werden, was man wirklich ist, wer man ist. Den hast du nicht gelesen. Du hast ja gelesen. Ich bin ein Paraphrasiker. Aber den hast du ja gelesen, das könntest du dir nicht wiedergeben. Glück ist, dafür geliebt zu werden, wer man ist. So, jetzt kann man das Gegenteil, ist entweder dafür gehasst zu werden, was man ist. Okay, Glück, Moment. Also das Gegenteil wäre, Glück ist, dafür gehasst zu werden, wer man ist. Glück ist, kannst du wie ausklammern, das ist ja nur das Folgende passiert. Und da wäre das Gegenteil, dafür gehasst zu werden, wie du bist. Aber trotzdem auch Glück. Ich bin glücklich, wenn mich alle dafür hassen. Das Gegenteil wäre ja Unglück, Doppelpunkt ist. Unglück ist, gehasst zu werden. Also, das ist wie ein Satz. Das Ding ist, es ist die Weisheit. Aber ich finde, du musst es schon inhaltlich ins Gegenteil bringen. Wenn dein Glück ist, gehasst zu werden, also so augenzwinkernd.
Aber Moment. Dein Glück wird es sein, gehasst zu werden.
Die Aussage ist ja eigentlich, sei wer du bist
und sei glücklich darüber,
über die Leute, die dich lieben, wie du bist.
Die Umkehrung wäre ja, um glücklich
zu sein, musst du jemand
anders werden.
Also
du wirst erst dann glücklich, wenn
du dich für die Liebe von anderen
veränderst. Das wäre die
Umkehrung. Das ist dann die Botschaft, die
Er hat sich in der Zeit, dass er die Zeit, die Umkehrung. Das ist dann die Botschaft, die tatsächlich ... Das Problem ist, es nicht ist, du wirst 10.000 Euro im Lotto gewinnen, sondern es ist ein Satz, der ist eine Weisheit, der setzt keine Handlung voraus. So, und jetzt wird es natürlich kritisch. Ich hole mir diesen Glückskeks am Bäcker für das Gewinnspiel. Jetzt steht in dem Glückskeks, du wirst großes Glück haben. Hab aber gleichzeitig eine Niete gezogen bei dem Gewinnspiel des Bäckers. Also ist es ja eine Art, also wie muss man das verstehen? Deswegen, ich finde das so, der Glücks-Glückskeks, finde ich, ist so ein Kontrast irgendwie, weil jeder Glückskeks, der nicht 10.000 Euro ... Du entwertest jeden anderen Glückskeks. ich will nicht fucking geliebt werden, wenn ich billig bin, ich will fucking 10.000 Riesen. 10 Riesen, oder? Das ist wie für jeden Lottoschein, den du nicht gewinnst, musst du zahlen. So ist, ja. Und dann bist du zum Gewinnspiel. Gutes Konzept, schreib's auf. Gutes Geschäftsmittel, schreib's auf. Wohin soll ich aufschreiben? Aber das ist so wie, also wenn du jetzt Christ bist und jemand snackt so diese Jesus-Oblaten, ist das respektlos? Also wenn du jetzt wirklich so, ich sitze zu Hause fett und bräsig und snack einfach diese Oblaten, würde man dann als Christ sagen, das ist respektlos? Nee, ich bin da sowieso knallhart, denk mir, wenn du was magst, ballerst die rein, egal wie das gedacht war. Das würde auf deinem Glückskeks stellen, wenn du es magst, ballerst die rein. Also wollen wir Glückskekse verkaufen, wo unsere Weisheiten in Teig gefasst, für die nächsten zehn Minuten aufgeschrieben sind. Aber wo ist sein, das ist da reingeschrieben mit Tinte einfach, auf die Oblate, die du isst. Nee, nee, drin, du musst aufbrechen und da drin ist ein Zettel. Der ist aber sehr dünn. Ganz dünn, auch dünn, und auf dem stehen christliche Weisheiten. Wollen wir nicht lieber so einen geilen Oreo machen, wo da drin einfach dann so ein Zettel ist oder so.
Gibt's bestimmt Firmen, die Glückskekse anbieten mit Texten, die man selber geschrieben hat. Für eine Schnitzeljagd zum Beispiel, wenn du eine Schnitzeljagd veranstalten willst zum Beispiel.
Okay, und was ist dann die Schnitzeljagd?
Naja, da stehen dann die Koordinaten. Ich überleg gerade.
Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, ne, ne, stopp, eine kölnweite Schnitzeljagd. Naja, da stehen dann die Koordinaten. Ich überlege gerade. Warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, ne, ne, stopp, ne Köln-weite Schnitzeljagd. Ja. So, wir vergraben einen Schatz. Neue Idee oder kommen die Glücksschäden wieder? 30 Prozent alte Idee, 70 Prozent neue Idee. Und zwar, wir vergraben in Köln einen Schatz mit ganz vielen, wirklich geilen Dingern, eine coole Lederjacke zum Beispiel, einen Barren Gold. Willst du dem Obdachlosen Lederjacke machen? Wir müssen Opfer bringen. 200 Euro in bar. So, und jetzt holen wir 100 Glückskekse und die versenden wir an zufällige Adressen in Köln. Wir machen 100 Pakete, versenden die Zufallsgenerator, verschicken die per Post an 100 zufällige Adressen in Köln. Jeder hat einen Hinweis in seinem Glückskeks. Und die hundert müssen sich finden und zusammenarbeiten, um gemeinsam die Schnitzeljagd zu machen. So, die müssen aber alle das Projekt kennen. Ja. Das Problem ist ja nicht. Ja, ja. Wie, und dann können alle hundert haben die Chance, die hundert Gegenstände zu finden. Ja, und dann ist es natürlich auch so ein bisschen Squid Game.
Also klar, du versuchst die anderen auszustechen oder versuchst denen diese Glückskekse abzunehmen oder sowas in der Richtung.
Aber am Ende kann man nur mit allen hundert Hinweisen das Ganze finden.
Um die Welt zu connecten, eine Million Dollar, der einfache
Teil, eine Million Dollar ist das Preisgeld,
ist irgendwo versteckt.
Das kann man nur mit fünf Hinweisen
finden, diesen Ort.
Man braucht alle fünf, sonst geht's nicht.
Diese fünf
sind auf allen Kontinenten,
ist ein Hinweis versteckt,
bei einer Person.
Okay. Also bei einer Person auf diesem Kontinent liegt diese Information. Alle müssen zusammenarbeiten, das Geld darf aber nur einer am Ende bekommen. Glaubst du? Okay. Weil mir kann es ja egal sein. Ich habe jetzt halt keine Millionen.
Okay, noch mal eine komplett andere Idee.
So wie Gummibärchen, nur ganz lang.
Oder noch eine andere Idee.
Ey, lass uns das machen.
Der 2025 Pufo-Schatz.
Und zwar, wir sagen Folgendes. Hey Leute, Abenteurer da draußen, Schatzjäger, aufgepasst, jetzt noch nicht, ihr schickt uns eure Adresse. Okay, pass auf! Ende. Wir verkaufen die Adressen gewinnbringend an Datenhändler. Oder? Aber ihr könnt nicht von profitieren. Wenn ihr wiederum von euren Freunden Adressen sammelt, zahlt ihr ja uns aber weiter. Aber jetzt sagen wir mal, wir kriegen 100 Adressen und verschicken 10 Hinweise an Leute aus der Community mit 10 Hinweisfragmenten und die müssen zusammen den Pufo-Schatz finden. Das ist halt langweilig für alle anderen, das ist für zehn Leute spannend. Die werden das ja im ... Aber das wäre doch viel geiler für alle eine Schnitzeljagd. Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum du anfängst bei diesem Konzept. Ja, aber wir können nicht hundert Hinweise machen. Nein, nicht hundert Hinweise, drei Hinweise, aber die Leute müssen halt cool, clever zusammenarbeiten oder sowas. Es ist halt viel Arbeit. Die werden das im Reddit ja wahrscheinlich zusammen, die müssen sich erfinden und koordinieren. Und dann werden die im Reddit dann die Hinweise posten und begleiten. Aber hat Peter einen Unfall. Hat Peter einen schlimmen Unfall. Ja, und war es Susanne? War es Susanne, die den Hinweis zwei hat? Vielleicht? Will Susanne den Pufo-Schatz für sich alleine haben? Noch eine ganz andere Idee. Okay. Ganz andere Idee. Das so wie in amerikanischen Filmen zu machen, dass man, wenn man auf die Voicemail spricht, auf die Mailbox spricht, man direkt das hört, live. Und dann kann man das annehmen. Weißt du, wie das bei amerikanischen Sitcoms immer so ist, dass du hörst live, wenn jemand auf die Mailbox spricht. Ah, du hörst es währenddessen. Am Handy. Du drückst jemanden weg, du drückst jemanden weg am Handy. Du hörst dann wie, ja hallo, Bonat von der Sparkasse Köln, Herr Tietze, ich wollte mich mal bei Ihnen melden, weil Sie lange nicht mehr bei uns waren. Und dann kannst du dann drangehen und sagen, ah, Sie sind's. Ah, okay, aber wir reden jetzt nicht von der Sprachnachricht, sondern von der, von der. Voicemail, Mailbox. Mailbox, ah, okay, verstehe. Viele gute Ideen auf jeden Fall dabei. Ich würde sagen, gutes Meeting, Leute. Ich würde sagen, da ist viel Fruchtbares rumgekommen. Vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart. So eklig, fruchtbar. Bah, ist das ein ekliger Ausdruck. Ich würde sagen, wir gehen damit jetzt alle noch mal schwanger. Das war so fruchtbar, dass wir, glaube ich, alle schwanger hier rausgehen. Ich glaube, jeder hat genug vom Fruchtwasser genippt heute. Ich glaube, da kam genug zu. Erst mal jetzt Schweißabwischen, Blut, wir haben Blutgeleckt. Ich habe Blutgeleckt, ich habe echt ein bisschen Pipi in den Augen. Und ich glaube, jetzt kann ich... Wir sind erst mal abgewichst. Okay, Jesus. Gut, dann müsste... Pipi in den Augen, so eklig. Dann bis zum nächsten Mal,
ihr Leute, gute Ideen auch von euch.
Vielen, vielen Dank, wir haben alles aufgeschrieben.
Haut rein, meldet euch.
Vielleicht machen wir dieses Jahr die
große Pufu-Schnitzeljagd.
Wir müssen noch überlegen, mir gefällt das System noch nicht,
aber wir kriegen das dann. Tschau, mach's gut, tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Zwischen.